[Musique]
donc je m'appelle apostin Vanessa donc
j'ai 33 ans donc je suis divorcée j'ai
deux filles de 12 ans et de 8 ans donc
je suis ici pour représenter la création
d'emploi donc mon emploi donc suite à ma
séparation donc voilà j'ai recommencé ma
vie à zéro j'ai préparé un Capp
d'esthétique en 2010-211 donc j'ai eu
mon diplôme suite à ça j'ai commencé à
travailler
et donc je j'étais censé racheter la
l'Institut de mon ma patronne donc ça
c'est pas fait pour diverses raisons
donc j'ai je me suis lancée à mon compte
donc j'ai j'ai ouvert mon institut en
2013 en mai 2013 donc je fais des soins
visage des épilations du maquillage
l'extension de cil très prochainement de
la réflexologie plantaire et je
développe le côté corps très
prochainement
voilà